look around you you haven't been  watching the dark corners of the world  may be living in a palace has made you  soft Your Majesty we have an unexpected  visitor I present the lost sister  Jessamine called delilah called win  impossible I'm here to relieve you of  your crown but someone yanked the rug  from under your feet you've lost your  throne and your father I promise delilah  won't just give the back so what are you  prepared to do about it your Imperial  Majesty  delilah's playing the long game  and now she's an empress  how many of your own subjects are you  ready to slaughter  and what are you willing to become  we'll be face-to-face soon Delilah